pour mieux comprendre ce que ça veut
dire cette enquête on en parle avec jean
françois ouellet télé professeur à hec
montréal merci d'être là monsieur
ouellette des plaisirs de soi expliqué
löw d'abord qu'est ce qu'on entend par
abus de position dominante
abbas un terme mais le sans rentrer dans
le jargon très légal des choses mais
c'est lorsqu'une entreprise qui jouit
d'une part de marché considérable
largement supérieur à l'ensemble les
autres joueurs sur le marché se permet
d'inonder des comportements qui
pourraient être perçues comme était
abusive c'est à dire par exemple
d'imposer à ses fournisseurs à ses
clients des termes et des conditions
qu'elles seraient pas en mesure
d'imposer si elle n'avait pas encore une
fois cette part de marché dominante le
faire des exemples que l'on voit dans le
marché qui sont absolument bien
documenté ce sont ainsi des heures
prévues par la loi anti monopole dans la
plupart des grands pays industrialisés
c'est lorsqu'une entreprise se permet de
prescrire à ces vendeurs par exemple
quel sera le prix de vente d'un produit
qui pourrait être vendu ailleurs eu
égard à ce qu'une fois aux différents
acteurs du marché
ouais et là dans ce cas ci la au canada
qu est ce qu il faudrait prouver qu est
ce qui rendrait amazon coupables de
pratiques anti concurrentielles
encore une fois je peux juristes dont je
vais me garder une petite gêne mais de
façon générale les poids des cas que
l'on voit dans ces cas de figure le
disons le comme ça c'est lorsque par
exemple une entreprise qui vint et
prenons un exemple vous vendez des
espadrilles vous êtes un manufacturier
d'espaly vous vendez sur amazon mais
devront également dans différents autres
dans différents autres types de
commerces qu'ils soient en ligne ou non
en ligne et amazon pourrait dans un col
mais je non le scénario là pourraient
prescrire avoue que manufacturier de
spyri en question de ne pas vendre pause
espadrilles à un prix moindre sur une
autre plateforme ou dans une autre
boutique que sur amazon ça deviendrait
la au sens de la loi illégale et là on
ne sait pas en ce moment c'est le début
de l' enquête le bureau de la
concurrence dit on n'a pas de preuves on
peut pas de tirer des conclusions mais
si vous parlez aux petits détaillants
que vous diront d'emblée que c'est déjà
presque impossible de rivaliser
et avec l'amazone est ce que déjà on
estime que c'est un concurrent jusqu'à
un certain point déloyale en fait ils
ont prétendu la maison haute vallée de
plein d'autres joueurs qui sont un peu
dans le même cas de figure parce que la
réalité c'est que vous avez deux choix
ve vous êtes un petit fabricant vous
êtes un petit commerçant vous décidez de
vendre via la plateforme amazon ou via
cosco ou via un autre grand détaillant
vous devez en quelque sorte acceptée des
conditions qu'elles soient explicites ou
qu'elle soit même plus ou moins
implicite vous avez comme pas le choix
de jouer le jeu si vous voulez
véritablement vendre sur ses plates
formes là donc est ce que on peut déjà
d'ores et déjà conclure que ça doit être
la façon dont ça se passe à l'heure
actuelle moi je rêve j'aurais pas trop
de doutes à croire que ça doit être des
jeunes comme maintenant de là le le
documenter et surtout à le prouver parce
qu'encore une fois tout se joue
absolument de manière beaucoup plus
implicite qu'explicite c'est à dire que
même par exemple le cas d'amazon amazon
va vous référencer en fonction de la
demande à l'égard de votre produit de
telle sorte à offrir un excellent
service à ses clients mais également de
telle sorte à ce que ce soit profitable
pour amazon elle-même donc si vous
vendez à le produit un produit qui ne
s'avère pas aussi profitable qu'un
deuxième produit pour amazon mais
absolument maisons devraient avoir
davantage tendance à promouvoir le
second que le vôtre et ça c'est une
technique qui encore une fois si on se
fie à la loi et à la lettre de la loi
pour être considéré légal être dominant
par contre monsieur ouellette ne veut
pas dire être le meilleur notamment
concernés et service à la clientèle
je te fais et de façon générale et
lorsqu'on voit émerger ce genre de
situation là bas généralement ça
correspond absolument un moment dans
l'histoire d'une économie de marché ou
d'autres joueurs commencent à tirer leur
épingle du jeu parce que ils sont
davantage spécialisés dans un créneau ou
encore parce qu'ils offrent une un
service additionnel en matière de
conseils par exemple en matière de degas
sortie ciment disponibles on a longtemps
parlé d'ailleurs par exemple de la
menace de wal mart lorsque moment et est
arrivée sur le marché canadien en disant
que ça allait tuer les petits commerces
5 la réalité c'est que vous avez tout et
rien chez webnet mais si vous cherchez
des pots en verre ben vous avez
peut-être je suis pas trop aux modèles
se connaît de chez huawei mais si vous
cherchez un modèle en particulier
définitivement vous allez vous tourner
davantage vers magasins spécialisés dans
ce genre de pots en verre
c'est la même chose en ligne amazon va
tout et rien théorie le catalogue
d'amazon est infinie sauf que on voit il
me renvoie émerger dans plein de
catégories de produits à l'heure
actuelle des joueurs beaucoup plus
spécialisés qui vont offrir davantage de
conseils de routage de services ou
encore un assortiment beaucoup plus
complet dans une niche particulière par
exemple aux états unis si vous avez des
animaux domestiques un show - chine la
plupart des gens vont acheter par la
plupart c'est encore en croissance très
fort mais vous avez un détaillant comme
chioui point com qui va vous offrir 150
sorte de bol pour la nourriture de votre
chien alors que vous allez peut-être
trouvé 10 sur amazon
donc est ce qu'on constate c'est la
raison pour laquelle pour un monopole y
en a encore des ventes en ligne et des
services plus spécialisés ailleurs on va
revenir juste avant de se quitter sur
cette enquête
si on finissait par déterminée au bureau
de la concurrence qui vient eu des
infractions qu'il ya eu des pratiques
anticoncurrentielles on a le pouvoir
d'imposer une amende de 10 millions de
dollars on a l'impression que l'on
manque de mordant ont peut-être un peu
davantage une tape sur les doigts
effectivement parce que bon concrètement
ce qu'est la le bureau de la concurrence
risquerait de faire l'homme de messages
qu'ils enverraient finalement c'est que
on vous a à l'oeil mais on voudrait
aussi la plus aux consommateurs
canadiens que ben déjà
force est de constater que dans
certaines catégories de produits puis
sauf aux classes de rappeler mais amazon
d'une position dominante dans le domaine
des médias des livres d'environ 70 % de
parts de marché à l'échelle
nord-américaine dans certains cas c'est
beaucoup moins que ça mais c'est déjà à
peu près 10%
ce seront en fait cette année ou l'année
prochaine qu'on atteindra le 10 % des
ventes totales du commerce de détail que
ce soit en réalisant en ligne c'est un
bond spectaculaire du notamment la
pandémie là on voit une croissance de
20% cette année
mais force est de constater qu amazon
dans sa position dominante
un créneau la vente en ligne qui prend
de plus en plus place d'un bureau de la
concurrence veut les avoir
définitivement beaucoup plus à l'oeil et
vous aussi monsieur ouellette d'ailleurs
je remercie beaucoup pour vos
explications avec plaisir avant